internet and citizens of reject nation
welcome back to another exciting episode
of koi's comic corner i am slightly
healed the voice is coming back i am no
longer quite the voice of doom but
slightly the voice of doom this episode
is very special because we're going to
talk about the entirety of phase five
going into six and how i think victor
von doom is going to be implemented in a
number of these properties and in fact
the big bad not necessarily kang but dr
doom pulling a lot of strings we're
gonna get to all of that but before we
do please like
leave a comment subscribe let us know
you love us i want to read these
comments i've been enjoying them and
speaking of which a lot of you asked
about these shirts the tie-dye shirts i
wear box lunch gifts the good folks at
box lunch clad me in this beautiful ware
tell him i sent you and speaking of
amazing comments i've been enjoying
reading thank you to everyone who has
followed me on tik tok you guys have
been amazing there's 15 second to three
minute videos over there a lot like what
i do here but in bite size little morses
if you think 20 minutes is too long you
got 20 second options get on over to my
tick tock and thank you to everyone who
has alright let's get into it
so before we get into doom himself kevin
feige has confirmed that fantastic four
is in fact not an origin story and that
ties beautifully into how i think
they're going to implement doom because
i think honestly doom is our way into
the fantastic four and i think that is
really interesting we've seen lots and
lots of these movies where the heroes
bring us the villain we haven't really
seen a villain bring us heroes and i
think those origins are gonna be tied
together really beautifully and we're
gonna be laying a lot of seeds
throughout an entire phase in the
beautiful way that we had thanos set up
through post-credit scenes through
little easter eggs through tie-ins
leading up to getting him an infinity
war let's go the other way let's use dr
doom to lead us towards the kickoff of
phase six with fantastic four now how do
i think we'll get there first of all we
get the knowledge that there is likely
and this is a rumor for now but we'll
see a post-credit scene featuring doctor
doom in wakanda forever that film is out
this year that is the conclusion of
phase four what better way to conclude a
phase than by kicking off your new
villain you have a post-credits scene
you set up through the film it looks
like we're going to have two nations at
war we've got the wakandans against the
atlanteans so it looks like we're going
to have a lot of really the trailer good
god we're gonna have a lot of stunning
imagery between these two rival nations
but if you're expanding the world
geopolitically if you're making
something as politically savvy as the
first black panther or further you're
gonna have other nations and what better
way to bring in doom than by having doom
look at the weakness of whatever culture
he's seeing what what snarky way to have
him introduce them by saying like oh
these people have fallen it's time for
me to you know use my power or just a
commentary on all of these meta humans
these overpowered beings clashing i
think latveria is introduced at the very
end of black panther and i think our
post-credits scene setting up phase five
is doom that's the rumor that's how i do
it i do think black panther is the
absolute best way to bring in everything
in the geopolitical landscape to come
now from there we're kicking off phase
five with quantum mania this is a great
way to kick off phase 5 because our
phase 5 villain does look to be kang now
i think our multiverse villain is going
to be doom now when you have your phase
5 villain with kang you're you're
introducing him after he's been soft
introduced as he who remains we've met
jonathan majors he who remains in loki
we saw comic accurate imagery of kang
but we haven't met him yet all of the
speeches that beautiful shakespearean
delivery in episode six of loki was
about how he's not the worst of them
he's protected them he's arguably the
good guy of the kangs we're about to
meet the real kang in ant-man
quantomania now i was fortunate enough
to see the ant-man trailer in hall h we
do see kang in all of his glory and he
is powerful he is intimidating and i
think throughout quantum mania this is a
film that takes place largely in the
quantum realm we're gonna see a lot more
time elements we're gonna see a lot more
reality and time manipulation which is
what kang is about which is going to set
the precedent for where phase 5 goes but
throughout that i think we're going to
be having slight hints at doom or
someone that might be working with kang
i think sometimes in the comics doom and
kang are simpatico for their greater
good i think where kang controls time
doom might control space as in physical
land i think these two are going to be
collaborative and i'm not sure if doom
will physically show up in quantum mania
but i would almost guarantee elements of
quantum mania will relate to doctor doom
as we kick off phase five now secret
invasion this is our big paranoid
thriller this one is a tv show that
looks like the most espionage elements
of winter soldier bringing us back to
that grounded reality what better way to
worry about the world being invaded by
aliens and the paranoia of are our
heroes who we say they are than by
bringing in a dictator i think this is
the first time we see him again i think
after the post-credits scene we might
now again see doom in his full glory i
don't know how much screen time i don't
know how big of a presence but i think
while we're seeing the world expand as
we're seeing the not just new york we're
no longer in phase one as we're seeing
everything in the mcu get more and more
global i think a great way to show
lavaria again and a great way to show
the power that doom wheeled setting just
again we're still at like level one of
breadcrumbs using doom as in i would do
that differently as doom being a certain
element of power and terror at a faraway
land again as this expands to a
worldwide secret invasion so now we've
met doom two maybe three times at this
point and that's great because it's a
lot like the comic books a lot of the
time doom is pulling the strings from
behind doors and he's in a few frames
but his presence is felt the important
thing about doom is that he's just so
imposing and he's got a nest for lack of
a better term he is always authoritative
and terrifying now i think we get to see
where he comes from i personally would
utilize his mother in the agatha show
his mother was a witch the powerful
thing about doom is he's as smart as
reed but he also wields magic there's a
lot of superheroes that are very
overpowered but magic is there for lack
of a better term krypt tonight doom
wields both science and magic if you
remember back to thor thor is talking
about how magic is just science you
can't explain yet i think agatha brings
that to play we've got chaos magic
already established in one division
we've got what corruption that does
already established what if doom and
doom's mother wield a form of chaos
magic what if agatha knows doom's mama
what if all of that comes in here and we
see the birth of the concept of victor
von doom if not victor von doom as a
child himself launching us through time
bringing us to adult doom in a more
established way by this point in phase
five now here we are with new world
order the world
distrusts heroes because of secret
invasion and because of the things i
think set up and miss marvel with the
department of damage control leading to
thunderbolt the world doesn't know what
to do with this new era of hero now in
the sam wilson captain america comic
books people don't like sam wilson
wielding the shield much like trolls on
the internet don't like sam wilson
wielding the shield we live in a
tempestuous world in our reality and in
the mcu's reality people like to let
chaos weaken nation people like to let
instability cause rifts in power i think
doom maybe not as much as he's an agatha
but i think doom might be implementing
here as someone that's trying to use the
weakness of a world fighting itself
which i do think is going to come into
play in new world order and i don't
think it's a coincidence that this film
leads into thunderbolts i think the
events at the end of new world order
with an instability with a nation
fighting itself with a rivalry between
heroes and the public all of these
things it's time for doom to want to
take over power and i think there's
going to be a lot of elements of him
between this and thunderbolts and from
there from thunderbolts i think we go
right into fantastic four now the
thunderbolts are a bunch of heroes that
are actually villains they're playing as
heroes to manipulate the public i'm
wondering if doom will literally be the
norman osborne of this world what if
instead of norman osborn a sony
character that has often led the
thunderbolts what if it's literally a
villain manipulating things now we do
have baron zemo and baron zemo is the
original leader of the thunderbolts i
would actually prefer they use baron
zemo i think daniel bruhl is fantastic
but if they don't doom's a cool option
now as far as fantastic four we now know
it's not an origin movie so we're going
from thunderbolts ending the phase five
into fantastic four kicking off as of
now as of what we know phase six what if
that conclusion what if that cliffhanger
is an avengers level event as the phases
have so far ended and then we kick off
with things in disarray things in chaos
what if doom has met the fantastic four
because he was scarred in the accident
that caused them but we meet them
through knowing more about this
character than them now we might
throughout phase five meet sue or reed
or even human torture ben graham there's
rumors that ben grimm is popping up very
soon but if we've got sprinkles of them
leading up to their team-up movie that's
a better way to build them like the
avengers right like remember we had
individual movies of these characters
then the avengers what if we meet them
and we kind of sympathize with doom what
if there's some empathy for this
character because we've met him as a
child in agatha because we we see how he
wants to rule his kingdom we maybe even
see how his people love them now
obviously he's a fascist he's a dictator
but that hasn't stopped americans from
loving dictators before you heard me
that might be the interesting way to go
into fantastic four with some empathy
for doom being conflicted by the
fantastic four in their first team movie
and that brings us to the kang dynasty
now this phase i've focused on doom
there's gonna be a lot of kang in it too
but i'm focusing on doom for this video
and that's important for this movie i
think with kang dynasty we've basically
had two villains running things in phase
five and that's really fun if that's
accurate i think it's gonna be a really
interesting way to differentiate the
multiverse saga from the infinity saga
because we've had a phase five lead kang
but now a phase six lead doom and i
think while the dynasty of kang is
running through time chasing his love
manipulating reality by way of time
travel and causing havoc throughout
centuries of problems for centuries of
different adventures i think the way the
kang dynasty ends is that what we
thought might happen at the end of loki
with the tva and everything exploding
what if reality itself can't handle the
amount of manipulation that kang has
caused what if the avengers have failed
to an even greater level than they
failed in infinity war what if reality
as we know it breaks
and the only person that can keep
reality together is doom using science
and magic and those fantastic four that
we just met can't be the heroes they
need to be doom is the hero keeping the
world together and bringing us
two secret wars our villain is also a
hero because he wants to rule everything
and he becomes the giant multiversal
king of this entire phase four five and
six
ruling secret wars now secret wars i'm
going to be brief because we could do we
could do 10 videos on secret but i think
secret wars is going to be a series of
elements that take place in shattered
realities i think all of the people that
wanted multiverse of madness to be fox
and sony and different continuity they
might get that with secret oars and i
think all of that is going to be held
together like in the comics with battle
world by dr doom now doctor doom is a
very powerful character i don't know
what that's going to mean with
manipulating these realities as far as
what he wields but that's why i think
there's going to be a kang and doom
element leading to this and that's why i
think secret oars might be literally the
biggest movie of all time as far as in
this genre i've been saying it for a
little bit that i think where end game
and infinity war were the culmination of
phases one through three i honestly
think secret wars is the culminations of
one through six not just four five and
six i think kang dynasty is basically
four five and six i think sears is one
through six and i think our biggest bad
today may just be a character that comic
fans have wanted for years to be handled
correctly i think we're about to meet
him and i think we're about to be
terrified of him throughout this phase
through many different properties for
years to come i think it's about to be
doom season and i cannot wait all right
chill lovelies these are just theories
this is conjecture this is all for
breeding way too many comic books read
some comic books if you want to know
which comic books i would recommend for
doom check out the doom video on this
very channel i did a whole breakdown of
who i'd cast as doom why doom's
important all of those elements and
those are still going to be in my comic
recommendations i love giving you guys
comic book wrecks please do check those
out and i promise in the next video i'll
give you some fresh new ones but in the
meantime please do like subscribe leave
a comment this video was because a bunch
of you said we want to see his doom
video i am listening i am reading those
and i do appreciate all the love you you
rejects are lovely so thank you for
having me here uh thank you for sharing
this video i'm seeing these views go up
and it means the world also you guys are
watching a [ __ ] ton of this like a lot
of it i see the length and it makes me
so happy please go tell your local comic
book store you love them tell your mom
give her a hug appreciate you guys i'll
see you soon
[Music]